what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
mgtow in 14 minutes before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring the notification bell as you
know 20 000 subscribers is a really big
goal
for me and the channel and each and
every one of you help
so this clip was actually sent to me by
a follower i know you guys have heard me
say this before but if you want to
submit clips
the best way is to send them to my
instagram if i don't respond like
immediately just keep bugging me about
it
um that's where i have like the least
amount of followers so it's easiest to
reach me but the men's
movement your kids probably have okay
wait
if you haven't yet heard about the men's
movement
your kids probably have it includes the
men's rights
movement focusing on legal issues and
the mgtow
branch which focuses on relationship
issues
they are sometimes together called the
red pill movement
feminists consider them both to be
misogynist
who are they they are youtubers such as
paul elims ear for men richard cooper's
entrepreneurs and cars
elliot hall sandman human a host of
others
uh many of them like to use foul
language
it's interesting because i've never
heard of any of these guys that i've
been reacting to nanosphere content for
like two months
i might have heard of the entrepreneurs
in cars but the rest of them i have not
heard most of these people
will recommend you to read
the rational mail by rolo tomasi
there's also a film out called the red
pill
the first thing you're going to have to
do if you're going to understand these
guys is to say
farewell to feminism feminist teaching
is that the only inborn differences
between males and females is their
reproductive organs
any other observed differences is a
result of social conditioning
feminists believe that if we do not
teach that the sexes are biologically
identical
we're going to perpetuate sexism okay
this part i actually
disagree with because um
so i'm one of nine kids like i have nine
siblings and
there's a reason that only the boys
became engineers
and most americans understand the
feminist view because from early
childhood
they've been immersed in it most
elementary school teachers are female
you're with your mother before school
masculine is teacher teaching is very
different
males and females have evolved very
differently both in our anatomy
and in our behaviors we're based our
social structure
on our inborn differences our biological
differences do not arise
from our social structure masculinist
scholars
believe that young men will be able to
navigate life successfully
only if they understand our evolved
differences
i would agree
i would agree with that like that all
seems right too okay let me give you
some
examples from the animal world this is
the male cardinal
it has a striking color to attract
females attracting females is its
strategy to pass its genes onto the next
generation
this display also makes the individual
vulnerable to predators this is the
female cardinal
it blends into the environment this is
its strategy
to pass on its genes to the next
generation this strategy also helps
the individual to survive
in some ways humans are like cardinals
males and females have developed
different strategies to pass on their
genes
and although both strategies work for
the species they work for the detriment
of males and for the benefit
of females guys you got to understand
this in the modern world
the first thing a young man must learn
is that biology's
biology works for the specie it is not
his ally he must learn to overcome or
control his biology
and use his brain if you're still under
some illusion that society set up for
the benefit of men and that women are
being oppressed
there are many youtubers out there ready
to dispel
these ideas hypergamy is key to
understanding the red pill movement
it is central to all of their other
concepts
okay this is is he going to read these
oh wait no no okay i got to go back i
just want to look for something
out there ready to dispel okay here we
go
the one that cares
oh wow okay so this is the one that
cares the least about the relationship
will control the relationship
how do you expect that to work in a
marriage
um meta-romantics
past masquerading
as pragmatics women are pragmatics
masquerading as romantics i don't know
what pragmatic means
that sounds like problem solver
true or false let me know in the
comments um
women need to be told no i think anyone
needs to be told no um
damn she's never yours it's just your
turn damn
unicorns don't exist don't believe your
woman is exempt from
all of this uh do you guys really
think that all women and all people in
general are the same
um a woman's message is her actions not
her words i i would say that's true for
like
all people like people
it's what they do not what they say
me males are expendable damn
not in a long successful marriage
um
uh women believe
it's natural and right for them to get
their way
okay that's kind of true um just because
a woman doesn't
understand her primal urges doesn't mean
you can't
okay this is a turkey theory is a better
predictor of women's behavior
than anything being advanced by
feminists or the mainstream culture
red pill thinkers believe our behaviors
are the result of over a million years
of survival and failure
as humans oh that's why they always
reference stuff is back to like
the olden days i always wonder why they
like talk about things that aren't
really relevant to me
like the caveman stuff i'm like what
does it matter in 2021 but
not if that's what they believe then
okay through all these millions of years
in which our behaviors were evolving
life was dangerous the mates of females
often faced
disabling injury when an injury made a
man
less able to provide food shelter and
protection a woman that stood by him
reduced her chances of passing her genes
on to the next generation
the female that transferred her loyalty
to a better provider
improved the chances of survival for
herself
and her offspring
so by this logic does that mean if you
lose your job
you no longer have a wife in
inter-tribal warfare
the men and children of a defeated tribe
would be slaughtered
the conquerors would view them as
opponents and competitors
the women because they had sex value
were captured
these women faced two choices
they could resist
they could go with them
the woman that resisted would increase
the chances that the victors would kill
her
her genes then would not be passed on to
the next generation
she's being weeded out the woman that
transferred loyalty to the conquerors
increases the chances that her genes
would be passed on
to the next generation her genes are
becoming stronger and stronger with each
generation
that's really interesting so that's what
they're basically saying that if a girl
moves on fast it's because
of her quote-unquote nature
that goes back to when tribes
slaughtered like another tribe and the
girls were like taken
okay i understand women the genetic
propagation strategy is to transfer
loyalty to the provider protector
that is the most capable of ensuring
survival
this how would they react
then to like
the marriage rate was a lot higher in
the early 90s i don't know the stats off
the top of my head
but i would imagine like the 40 50 60
year marriages that lasted through like
the great depression
by this logic wouldn't they say that
everyone got divorced let me know in the
comments if you have any stats
to that would like make sense her
disproportionate
is called hypergamy
hypergamy continues to exist today as a
woman's
primal urge to move to a male of higher
status
thus hypergamy is the golden or central
concept of red pill philosophy
hypergamy defined once again is a
woman's primal urge
to transfer whenever possible her
dependence to a male with a higher
status status
depends on her values if she values
toughness and a tougher man moves into
the neighborhood
she will attempt to jump ship to him if
she values wealth
then she'll attempt to land a wealthier
man well wouldn't that mean
nobody would stay together then because
there's always going to be someone
better at something if she values
religion she may turn her attentions
from a man in the pew to a man in the
worship team
all of this doesn't mean that she's
consciously duplicitous
many women will act on their primal
urges without analysis
or even awareness so let's talk about
the
silver concepts those concepts that
support your understanding of hypergamy
number one
just because a woman doesn't understand
her own primal urges
doesn't mean a man can't
this is great news for men men can
understand
women for men who have been told their
whole lives
that a woman is mysterious this is great
news
women often live with a just go with a
flow unplanned life
in which they can still end up where
they want i mean how many women have
ended up saying things like
i never planned on running off with him
i've literally never heard a girl say
that
it was like it was meant to be i've
never heard a girl say that to me in
real life
or look we didn't do this to hurt you it
just
sort of happened no i've never heard
anyone say that i mean i'm not only
talking
of her own foreign urges her words are
usually reflecting some idealized image
of the truth
the only reliable method of knowing
anything about her then
is to observe her
so a woman's words are not her message
her actions are her message
i wonder if you can use these concepts
for men
too because it says a woman's words are
not a message but
i would say it doesn't matter what
people say it matters what they do it's
like the same thing
so this means when a woman is texting a
man five times a day the message is not
the inane chatter in the text
the message is i'm texting you five
times a day
likewise when she gives a man positive
words
but doesn't pick up when he calls the
message is not in the face-to-face
banter if the message is
i'm not picking up your call
huh but
i don't understand how this is just for
women
wouldn't that be either gender one will
write or
quipped hark what they say you'll be led
astray
watch what they do you'll know what is
true
silver concept three men are romantics
masquerading as pragmatists
women are pragmatists masquerading as
romantic i still don't know what a
pragmatist is
prague i'm a tiss
let me see a person who is guided by
practical
considerations more than her ideas oh
okay so they're saying like
women are actually like practical but
they're pretending to be romantic
once again it's not that women are being
consciously false
since they haven't thought through what
they want if you ask them
they'll report a romanticized idealized
image but when they act
they will act according to hypergamy
in this way women appear to be romantics
but their reality will usually
reveal a net gain
for women love is not the motivating
factor
a woman awards her love to the man that
wins her
men who often portray themselves as the
solid ones
are stunned at how quickly their lover
moves on
it is men not women that commit suicide
when the relationship is over
it's interesting because what i've seen
has been the opposite of that like i've
seen
men move on quicker than women but let
me know in the comments what you get
the partner that needs the relationship
the least will control the relationship
the principle of least interest is the
idea that the person with the least
interest in continuing the relationship
has the most
power in that relationship the person
that needs the relationship the most
has the fewest options he or she is much
more likely
to give in silver concept five
nice guys are beta women need an alpha
i hate the words alpha and beta i've
heard it way too much in the manosphere
and the reason i'm not a big fan is
because literally in the manosphere they
call everyone a beta
like like i've seen them call the most
like successful mask like in my opinion
like
seemingly masculine guys beta
because like for what think about the
woman who says
where have all the nice guys gone why
can't i find a nice guy
how come i keep ending up with jerks
or think about the guy who thinks if
only she'd tell me what she wants
i would do it both these people are
asking for an impossible thing the woman
needs to know she's
not the one wearing the pants that she's
not the alpha in the pair bond
women need a man to be an alpha one way
of being an
alpha is to be a jerk she continues to
fall for jerks to fulfill her feminine
alpha need on the other hand
what about him if a man needs a woman to
tell him to be the alpha
then he isn't one he can't be one
this is why women continually test men
women need reassurance they have an
alpha
men who easily give in to women's
demands
are not the alpha they can't stand up to
her
desire cannot be negotiated
when the love is gone no amount of
arguing or negotiating
can make the other person desire you
women are human beings men are human
doings we are society that values a man
for what he does in the world
a woman for how she looks
yeah i'd say that's true later
yeah that's definitely true create a
graph with age
along the horizontal and attractiveness
along the vertical then we would see
that a woman's
reproductive appeal peaks between 23 and
25.
a woman that fails to secure a mate
during her peak
will notice a drop in male attention in
the 27 to 33 age range
a woman past 35 is looking for security
yeah that makes sense meanwhile as young
women
are peaking young men are just starting
their careers
the peak women are out of their league
however men generally reach their max
appeal to women later about 34 to 36
as they solidify their careers
i think i've seen this chart before yeah
that makes sense
many mgtow men ridicule that woman who
squanders her youth and
ends up here alone
earned equity is a fallacy
if you remember earned equity value a
man for what he does
then men think that when they do they
are
earning the relationship but
it doesn't count none of the things they
do count
for anything when hypergamy hits it's
over
breifult's law is that the relationship
lasts as long as it benefits
the woman huh i want to react to this
with my dad because my parents have been
married for a really long time
and i'm really curious to see what he
would say this is the praying mantis
immediately after mating the female
devours the male
he's nothing more than available
resources for the perpetuation of the
specie
biology was not his ally
males are disposable
but this has always been so during the
early years of the human race
we lived in a state of inter-tribal
warfare
the survival strategy that was adopted
was for
men to defend the tribe the tribe didn't
last long if its men would not risk
their lives to defend their people
men with no inborn aggression seldom
pass their genes on to a new generation
and that's like the alpha winning
strategy for the tribe as a whole
was for the males to face danger in
order to provide
and protect the individual males
were expendable our society continues to
embrace this very
early view because it is hardwired into
our biology
today men hold almost all jobs with risk
of loss of life
we accept that men are expendable
oh wow i wouldn't have put it like that
but i think it's more like men choose to
be expected like they choose those jobs
women don't want to be 30
of workplace fatalities are male
99 of us combat deaths are male
in our culture men continue to be
expendable
it's a strategy that benefits the race
but not the individual
male a woman cannot be the center of a
man's
life yeah that's true a woman should
compliment a man's life
not be the center of it mgtow men are
going to focus on their careers or
pursuits
and not play the game anymore
unicorns don't exist in other words
don't
i hate it when people say unicorns don't
exist you act like
everyone acts the same and that's the
that's the thing that i really disagree
with like the manosphere on
is when you view the world through a
certain lens obviously you're gonna view
things that way but that doesn't always
match up to what you see in real life
um to act like i don't know
there's billions of people
on earth and they all act exactly the
same woman is example five of this
okay that was that was interesting i
thought that really laid out like that
was a really well put together video it
really laid out like the manosphere
ideas that i've
heard so much about in the last couple
months uh let me know in the comments
what you agree with what you disagree
with
and put a video that you want to see me
react to
next i will talk don't forget to
subscribe i don't forget to say it do
not forget to subscribe i'll talk to you
guys
next time